c'est le gouvernement utilise le 49-3 ce
sera un déni de démocratie
je dirais même scandale démocratique ce
serait la triple peine c'est à dire non
empêcher la rue de s'exprimer et
syndicats le peuple empêché le parlement
de s'exprimer directement et troisième
chose est utilisé cela c'est ça va dans
le contresens de l'histoire
je pense que les contes les conséquences
pour la majorité serait très grave au
niveau municipal
le gouvernement dit que qui ne peut pas
faire autrement c'est à cause de
l'opposition à cause de son obstruction
à qui la faute si on veut effacer
l'opposition le dis clairement il n'y a
pas de position donc on fait un texte on
se taire le pays
il ya une opposition c'est ça la
démocratie ça s'appelle la dialectique
politique c'est à dire la possibilité de
se contredire et trouver une synthèse
savait à ce niveau là pour une telle
réforme
karl réforme systémique de très grande
ampleur qui va conduire inéluctablement
à des modifications radicales et nous
considérons qu'il y aura une perte
andine de pension pour la plupart des
gens et à ce titre là on devait peser
discuter laisser la contradiction se
faire pour pouvoir décider ensemble
je prends un exemple vous engager notre
discussion du texte ou fait une
conférence de financement qui va
influencer sous le texte
c'est vraiment une ambiguïté incroyable
c'est un flou artistique d'ailleurs le
conseil d'état l'a constaté je considère
que la le gouvernement c'est lourd à
porter la responsabilité de la confusion
actuelle mêlant ces derniers jours ces
dernières semaines on assiste à de
l'obstruction de la part de l'opposition
pour ralentir les ailes l'opposition
utilise les moyens
qui sont à disposition de l'opposition
c'est vrai qu'apple certainement au
niveau de certains groupes quelques
excès mais que voulez vous que ces gens
fassent
on ne peut pas influencer que par le
débat c'est ce qui se passera non groupe
socialiste on a décidé d'utiliser un
autre club le mans les progressistes et
socialiste c'est de demander dans le
cadre d'une comme son enquête de
vérifier la teneur des propos les
analyses les propositions et qui ont des
fêtes parce que c'est très important si
les paramètres qui sont indiqués ne sont
pas justes et vraies conseil d'état aura
raison et personne ne comprendra comme
on a pu donner une étude d'impact
complètement tronqué qui conduit à
l'élaboration de textes qui
nécessairement sera ponk est aussi et
pour les outre mer de la ce
les questions relatives à l'outre-mer ne
sont pas aux dispositions savoir être
patient ordonnance dans tous les cas
vous n'aurez pas volume au chapitre j'ai
failli dire que c'est une habitude on
traite d'outre-mer comme une espèce de
l'adjuvant est à côté quoi ce sont des
ordonnances in à 29
il ya plusieurs qui vont concerner le
premier est aujourd'hui les populations
de france mais de l'hexagone mais aussi
dû trouver on ne se rend pas où nous
allons par exemple le calcul de la
valeur du point qui va déterminer la
pension on sait pas comment le calcul et
on se bat on a dit ce qu'on ne connaît
pas est-ce qu'on intègre des 40% ou pas
moi je suis favorable dans le calcul des
pensions
on va voir on sait pas mais qui va payer
les cotisations qui sont afférentes aux
cars pour cent on ne sait pas oui on va
mettre une retraite 1000 euros de base
pour notamment les agriculteurs ceux qui
n'ont pas de travail et le mode de
calcul fait que l'activité informelle et
c'est ça concerne les coupeurs de
bananes des planteurs de bananes des
coupeurs de cannes etc
les pêcheurs les chauffeurs de taxi dans
nos pays et ce c'est une activité
informelle il n'y a pas de pièces pour
prouver l'activité ces gens ne pourront
pas avoir accès à ces millions qui a un
tas de choses top truck quoi qui qui à
mon avis et ne fait qu'accroître et la
confusion qu'il y à déjà dans ce texte
l'aise dans la politique menée